I've played numerous Pokemon games over
the years because I enjoyed them for
what they were simple RPGs that offer an
incentive to collect and raise a stable
of quirky creatures but after 20 years
of following the same formula I'm ready
for a change
the pokken tournament the upcoming
fighting game from Bandai Namco Pokemon
battles have evolved giving you total
control over pokemon in a way the series
never has before after almost an hour
with the game's dynamic combat system I
think I found the answer to my Pokemon
problems pokken tournament is a far cry
from the Pokemon games that have defined
the series you don't get to capture and
raise Pokemon in the traditional sense
hookin is a fighting game first and
foremost that shares the same spirit of
Smash Brothers it's an accessible game
with easy-to-understand controls that
allow anyone to jump in and have some
fun but there's also depth for those who
want to hone in and compete on an
advanced level certain moves take
priority over others and while elements
don't play a factor into matchups
between different Pokemon their tendency
is to fight and close their long range
can have an impact on your strategy each
Pokemon has a light and heart attack the
ability to jump block and throw and the
meter based first mode that they can tap
into getting temporary stat buffs and
access to a powerful burst attack until
the meter drains after activation
fights featured two phases which switch
when a pokemon delivers significant
damage to their opponent every match
starts with the field face where two
pokemon move around a 3d space lobbying
long-distance attacks of one another but
once they get close and start to
exchange blows the game typically shifts
into its duel fans where pokemon move on
a fixed 2d plane similar to traditional
fighting games like Street Fighter
during matches you also have the option
to bring out support Pokemon to attack
or interrupt your opponent or lend your
character a brief stat bug once the
Pokemon is called into battle you have
to wait for its gauge to recharge before
you can use it again but it doesn't take
long you typically get to use your
support Pokemon multiple times during a
single fight core mechanics of poking he
fights interesting providing a varied
array of tools that each fighter can use
on top of their already unique movesets
some Pokemon are better up close while
others are optimized for rain of combat
zipping across an arena and dishing a
fantastical attacks feels great and it
gave me a new appreciation for the
creativity and viewed into each poker
without question throwing lightning
bolts as Pikachu is far more exciting
than telling people to do it and just
watching it play yeah the shift in
control felt great and it came easy it
only took a few matches before I had a
handle on any given Pokemon and I could
see how in the hands of a passionate
competitor hook ends true potential as a
fighting game could be unlocked hook and
tournament could be the game that brings
weary players into the series for the
first time and for anyone with an
existing affinity for Nintendo's
creature kitchen classic it may be the
game that refuels their passion in a
suit
changed little since the 90s pokken
tournament is coming out to Wii U in
North America on March 18th